you
[Music]
okay so it's a great pleasure to
introduce professor Karthik pata Berman
from University of British Columbia
Karthik got his PhD in 2009 from the
University of Illinois in Champaign
Urbana and he spent a year at Microsoft
Research working with me as a postdoc
and 2010 since then he joined the
faculty at the University of British
Columbia and has worked in the areas of
resilience security JavaScript web
programming and today he's going to talk
about two interesting topics one is IOT
and the issues around building a secure
and reliable IOT systems the other is
looking at systems built on top of
neural networks and how understanding
the resilience of those systems is very
important especially in the growing
areas in which they're being applied so
with that thank you very much present
Thank You Ben
thank you everyone both listening online
and we're here so it's great to be here
as Ben mentioned there was a postdoc
here about five six years ago and have
very good memories so I'm going to be
talking today about a couple of recent
projects we've been doing in my group my
background is mostly in fault tolerance
and security and this is applying
classical fault tolerance security
techniques to two emerging area
self-driving cars and smart devices so
this joint work with my PhD students as
well as collaborators from Nvidia
research so my research broadly is on
building error resilient and secure
software systems so work on three broad
areas on software resilience techniques
web applications in JavaScript
programming and recently and
cyber-physical system security I'll talk
more about this this talk but the focus
here will be cyber security cyber
physical SiC system security and
resilience so what are cyber physical
systems so these are systems we interact
with on every everyday basis are they
more more than our Tower which is IOT so
if you look at a modern car for example
it's mostly a computer that your that
controls many of the essential functions
so for example when you press the brake
pedal at a certain speed it's an
indication to the computer that you want
to slow down there's no physical
hydraulics anymore alleys in most cars
smart meters many of us have these in
our homes they are also followed by
embedded microcontrollers that's a nest
thermostat
you know which is recently acquired by
Google but there's many other such
devices as well and of course embedded
medical devices in the human body so
these are examples of cyber-physical
systems which have to interact with the
environment and as a result their safety
and security is extremely important so
that's the good news
so what unfortunately the the bad guys
are never far away so to speak so there
are a lot of security and reliability
issues that come to the fore so perhaps
the most well-known is the hack on the
bordered car these guys a Wired magazine
they were able to attack a car this was
going down the highway there's been work
from u-dub on smart you know pacemakers
and spot medical devices there's also
been tons of attacks on smart meters I
won't add them to list them all but
people have shown that pretty much you
can make your smart meter read whatever
you want including negative values of
power consumption if you like and it was
a nest thermostat I don't know of any
attacks but there was a famous Blitz
chatting in January 2016 where it went
down and after a software upgrade and
pretty much the temperature inserted
below the dead of winter so it's not
just security of these devices even the
natural failures are very important so
with that said how different are these
systems from regular desktop or laptop
computers so there are a bunch of
challenges that cyber that are unique to
cyber physical systems so first as many
of these systems operate in the real
time constraints so for example the
pacemaker I mean that's an extreme
example you have to deliver a pulse
every one or 1.5 seconds but many other
systems also have similarly and time
constraints like in your break when you
hit your brake pedal in your car you
better convey that information to the
computer within a certain amount of time
or else you might hit the car in front
of you so there are these constraints
there are also resource constraints
because a big fraction of you know many
of these devices are extremely
resource constrained and they're very
cost sensitive so to give you one
example as typical smart meter cost a
few hundred dollars even adding some
extra memory on that would actually
increase its caused by ten to twenty
percent so which many of these
manufactures don't want to do so
likewise in a modern car I've been told
that computers at least 20% of the cost
especially when you move the
self-driving cars and so on so these are
cost constrained as well they're hard to
upgrade because they need to operate
continuously often in remote
environments so you can't restart them
on an ongoing basis and often there's no
human-in-the-loop right so you can't ask
for confirmation of an action or when
the system is dealing with a important
event like a life critical event you
can't have a human say is this this is
action they want to do so that's the
other challenge that comes up so with
that broad motivation I'm going to be
focusing on two specific systems in this
talk so one is you're going to look at
look at some work we did on resilience
of deep neural network accelerators
employed in self-driving cars and here
we are focusing on soft errors or
Hardware faults which caused single
event upsets a bit flips in these in
these systems and in the second part of
the talk I'll talk about intrusion
detection systems for smart embedded
systems that for which we use dynamic
invariant detection technique has been
used in software engineering but here we
adapted it to cyber physical systems and
then I'll talk about some of the ongoing
work and my group around this theme as
well as some conclusions so I don't need
to stand here and tell you that
self-driving cars are big they're
depending on who you are they the five
years in the future or 15 but everyone
acknowledges at some point they'll be
here big companies are investing a lot
of money into this you know but but more
broadly
one of the main technologies that make
self-driving cars possible is deep
neural networks or the ability to
recognize the cars pedestrians etc and
take action accordingly so this is
definitely a safety critical application
nobody wants to be in a self-driving car
which is only partially correct so you
know these are it's very important that
we get this right another important
constraint here is there a real time
constraint so you you want for example
your car to look at the image and then
classify it
appropriately within a fraction of a
second over then some time bound and
period so that you can take action so
what many of the companies in the space
have been doing is investigating
specialized accelerators hardware
accelerators that they can deploy on
these self-driving cars so to run deep
neural networks now there have been
other instances of accelerators for deep
neural networks as well like the data
center space I'm not going to talk about
it now but many of these many what I'm
going to present today many of the
results also apply in that space now why
do we care so much about self-driving
cars in particular so I'll show you
examples where even a single bit flip
can actually cause miss classification
but more importantly in these stay in
this little particular space they're
actually very there's very strict
regulation so you have to make sure or
you have to prove that your chip has a
what they call a fit rate of failures
over a billion hours of less than 10
overall and this is for the entire chip
not just the you know the DNN part so
these are standards or ISO 26262
enforces this and if you are a company
that manufactures chips for these cars
donuts on you to show that you meet that
standard so it's a very real problem so
this is regardless of any other source
of error you've got to show the fit rate
to be with him that little add-on so one
of the big challenges in modern
electronics is software so where you
have as for particles or cosmic rays
come and upset your transistors and
either lead to charge deposit or charge
depletion someone go to the device
physics of this but what happens is if
you have some electronic compass like a
door for example or a multiplexer what
you might end up doing is getting a
wrong bit turn it so zero zero zero one
you get zero one zero one similar things
apply to flip-flop storage elements as
well but at the from a high-level
programming perspective these manifests
as value corruptions and you know
there's been numerous instances of
software is actually affecting business
critical applications the famous one
being son had to recall their servers
things back into those at one and it
made the front page of New York Times
and there were other you know similar
events that actually caused bad
publicity as well as losses billions
so these are things that chip designers
have to worry about now I tried just one
graph you're so soft errors have been
increasing in computer systems at least
for over the last decade or so this is a
graph from shaker berker so the x-axis
is the feature size or the number of
nanometers using today or like sixteen
or even eight nanometers and the y-axis
is relative units so these companies
never tell you the actual error rates
they show you little error rates and you
can see that's going up exponentially
right so so this is a real problem and
it's going to get worse as we integrate
more and more electronics on the chip
now you might stand in and say haven't
we solve this problem yes yes man of
course yeah oh sure
so if the error is you graph like that
anyway even independently DNS stuff how
they protecting the card chips now right
because it sounds like it's you know
they have to be some strategy because so
that's a great question in fact that's
they got banned it so they say okay I'm
going to I know that at this voltage the
probability of it actually flipping the
debate is very high so I'm going to
double the voltage for example right or
they do things like I'm going to
replicate certain parts of the pipeline
with DMR and I don't I don't necessarily
think those are panaceas but they might
work for more traditional you know CPUs
very have a larger power budget and
performance budget in the DNN case
listen cuz i overhead another strategies
ECC or parity or whole storage elements
so they have real time constraints so
you can't go replicate your critical
path for example and other another thing
people have tried to do is there's been
lot of work on generic micro
architectural solutions but these are DN
an algorithm agnostic and they end up
being non optimal for these systems
especially to give you one example a
technique we developed that other
researchers have developed will
selectively duplicate the computation so
figure out which parts of a program are
really influential to the output and
then duplicate that this doesn't really
work on a DN and because the actual
program is like five instructions so you
duplicate it okay you know you pay under
person overhead or very over it
so so these are very different beasts
from your traditional programs that run
on you know regular CPUs and so on
I do have we do have other work in my
group looking at how to protect programs
running on CPUs as well as GPUs from
soft errors I'm not going to talk about
that today but however there are similar
challenges in that space as well so a
very brief overview of a deep neural
network I'm not a machine learning
expert but this is sort of my
understanding of this so you have
multiple layers in your neural network
and in each layer has specialized
functions so so you have an image you
you feed it into the first layer and it
goes and classifies it into one of many
categories so there are different
feature maps as a convolution layer
subsampling layer and so on and
different neural network architectures
have different combinations of these
layers so when I get into the details of
the experiments we did I talked about
which sets of layers we consider and the
other side of this is so this is from
abstract level but the accelerators
actually have an architecture that lets
you you know implement those layers
directly in hardware without going
through the software so there is the
software simply says do convolution but
that operation is done indirectly in the
hardware and the way they do it is they
have this array of crossing elements so
this is an example of an architecture
from MIT called iris so they have a
global buffer in which which goes to the
DRAM so that's where you fetch the data
and then the data gets streamed to these
processing elements so these all solve
like spatial computation again yeah your
question thank you so many of these have
very similar picture in fact community
there are a dozen of these various
people are proposed we looking at one
particular one which is iris but its
results are not confined to this so we
try to canonicalize the architecture
here so we try to make it as generic as
possible and and what Appy yes sure
that's or they are previous to in the
research
okay there are some products out there
okay I found a lot to say anything about
the specifics of the Nvidia architecture
but Google or any STP you know and there
are other set architectures as well okay
but what we are doing is using an open
source architecture for iris which was
proposed the research community so
anybody so the processing element it's a
nine of crossing elements and crossing
element is basically encoding these
operations that are clean hot as it is
iris actually of chip yes so they join
his group at MIT they release the
chimpanzee measured so there'd be a
couple of others is this there's a group
from China where they also have a
similar chip for doing BN ends so so so
they're not the only game in town
by any means but you know it was as good
as any of the other architectures and
one of the things they have going for
the muscles they can do dynamic
reconfiguration on the fly so they claim
at least the the goal is to have more
adaptivity unlike some of these others
where once you once you fix the
architecture you're stuck with that so
designer so I can't speak on the merits
or demerits of iris versus other
architectures but I'm told it's fairly
typical of many of these DNN action
writers so the goal here what we are
trying to do is understand error
propagation in DNA and accelerators
through fault injection so I'll tell you
what we exactly be in by fault injection
second we want to both quantify the
probability as well as characterize it
and of course we want to mitigate the
failures right so the goal is to gain
insights so that we can come up with
efficient ways to detect errors and I'll
tell you later but some hardware as well
as software techniques we develop to go
and detect these faults so what is fault
injection as the name suggests we go and
put up different values in the actual
implementation of these neural networks
on the chip according to a fault model
and then we we study the effects so we
consider for numeral networks here
Cornett Alex net cafe net and ni n
and the datasets are given as well so
these are fairly standard in this
community so there's a whole bunch of
input datasets and they come with and
the number of output candidates tells
you how many how many classes they
classify the result into there are
different ways of implementing these
neural networks you can use fixed point
just for the floating point so we looked
at all these data types so we look at 16
bit as well as 32 bit fixed point so to
give you an example a 16 bit fixed point
has one sign with five integer bits and
ten fractional bits only tell that but
and 32 bit I'll be more specific about
what we exactly consider when we present
the result and likewise for floating
point so these are being proposed by
researchers in terms of saying for
certain neural networks certain data
types are better but we look at the
whole gamut of it
so how do we do the fault injection so
we actually inject three thousand random
faults in each latch in each layer of
the neural network so so we mostly
consider faults in sequential elements
because this is a dominant fault model
today we use a simulator
it's called tiny CN n is written in C
and what we do is we emulate faults that
occur in the hardware into the C code so
an example would be okay this is very
simplified code it says for each layer
for each weight for each input so
instead of actually doing a computation
there we would go and inject a fault
using our function okay we've also
verified that this corresponds to the
result of beam testing experiments the
and in the places where I've inject
Falls or places where real Falls would
observe and we put these under Neutron
beeps so so we've we built this fort
injector we consider a single bit flip
fault because that's the dominant fault
model for for transient faults we also
consider a we consider faults that
occurred latches in the execution units
as well as storage buffers ligustrum
scratchpad and resistor so in a nutshell
we inject faults in pretty much any
sequential element in the in the chip
and we do this multiple times 1 fault
per run to get statistical estimates so
before I tell you about the results then
we sort of put up the there's a
mandatory slide and what's the
consequence of a silent data corruption
as we call it where some data gets
calculate so this is from a real fault
injection experiment we did
okay we did for many such cases but this
is an illustrative one so the neural
network was supposed to classify this
truck of course is a truck for did
enough classifying it is a bird now
depending on your we did actually put
this on a real self-driving car so you
don't know what really happened but my
guess is if it sees a bird it's normal
to thrown out right so that could be a
problem so we found many cases where a
single bit flip can actually cause the
whole bnm to to be misclassified yes
Angele into the first layer there is
possibility that you inject a bit of
flip the very last moment when Danny
tried to output so we try to be lined up
right so if 99% of the time is being
spent in the first few layers then
there's only one percent probability
we'll inject into the last layer right
so we we try to burn em away what
happens in reality so the layers are
getting executed on the you know on the
accelerator so any of these could
actually be subject to false however
I'll show you later the distribution of
this so I guess I know miss something
right and this is the connection between
the C program and the chip oh the C
program is an architectural simulator so
all I'm trying to say here is we do the
injection in the architectural simulate
in the covered like simple scalar for
CPUs right so there is a DNN simulator
acceleration simulator here and we we
identify which parts of that simulator
actually mapped to the hardware and we
know those paths that are the
susceptible in hardware and we inject
the fault in the simulator when there's
just a way for us to do the fault
injection without having to twiddle with
FPGA is in the like this problem is not
very specific
this kind of children no it's not so we
have to do the whole thing that's great
but but we did their mapping and we've
also validated it with your own business
so whenever it's company's leadership
they put in a realtor on beam to see
that it has a current so the first order
of approximation we know these are
places where dinners occur right
but of course with all abstraction we do
lose some information so one of the
things about it is that the
classification loop just like I'm just
going to reclassify presumably decide
that's a right truck because you know
one one frame out of 100 or wherever
instead of saying it's a bird isn't so
bad but okay so that's a good point so
it depends on the speed of at which you
classify so typically you know I've
heard numbers from 0.3 to 0.5 seconds
for each reclassification depends on how
far that for later is now this is for
this particular platform right but think
of it this way if you're going at 70
miles per hour you have half a second to
slam on your brakes so that your you
know by the laws of physics your
self-driving car comes to a stop
depending on your depending on the
distance to the object so I'm not
claiming that all of these will result
in collisions or even at once but so
again let's go back to the standards so
just and let's say that if you have a
failure like this this this can occur no
more than one or ten every billion are
so that's ten fit for a whole chip so
even if maybe maybe you are lucky and
this didn't actually cause a collision
you it's still you'll still fail to be
the standard if you don't actually
guarantee that so that's that's at least
the the goal we have sent here your
question so so we are a bunch of
research questions here so we said I
know what are the violent attacks oh I
should have mentioned this so silent
data corruption as a standard term we're
using for measuring where the output
actually the first from the correct
output under a fault injector block I'll
tell you more about how we actually
determine whether something is silent in
a corruption or not so we looked at what
are the DC rates and
Indians for different data types and
then we looked at sensitivity on a bit
level basis of which bits are sensitive
and then we looked at the actual values
themselves how far they're from and
they're in fact okay maybe just yes yes
by significant okay and we see how so
but before going further should define
the kinds of silent data corruption so
so it's a little keep in mind that a DNN
is not like your pro not like a typical
program that you put one answer right so
a bit is often the answer you can say
over the program was wrong here you know
you it might output the other that
that's acceptable regardless of whether
or no that's the correct answer
so we call the first kind of SDC what he
called as DZ one is you so you you have
a mismatch between the winner the
top-ranked answer from the correct
network to the 41 then we looked at the
SDC 5 which is the winners not on the
top five predictions so so you might
argue look you know if it says even in
one of the five predictions it's a truck
it should stop right so look at how far
away that was and then we do the same
thing for 10% or 20% so the confidence
that winner
so the neural network also outputs a
confidence saying I'm ninety percent
confidence is a truck and ten percent
confidence is a bird right so the
confidence drops with more than ten
percent and 20 percent that's also an
issue because now they know essentially
you don't know what it is or many of
these things have thresholds that say
for example for me to apply a braking
action I need to be 90 percent sure
there's an obstacle in front of me so so
that's not assured we are working with
so I'll explain the graph but first I
just want to show you the overall trends
here so the x-axis is the different
kinds of position double float float 16
16 RB 10 is when you have a 16-bit fixed
point but you're you you have
ten places for your you know for the for
they for the ninth design six places for
the five places for the exponents or
five bits for the exponent and 32 Arbeit
Edna's when you have ten places of the
decibel and up 21 places or 21 bits for
your exponent and and so on so we also
looked at the different kinds of SDC so
zc1 as dc5 as SDC 10% as DC 20% and one
thing that stood out oh and the bars are
the different you know the different
shadings of the different neural
networks so one thing that stood out
across all of this is that the 32 RB 10
has a very significant SDC rate as you
can tell right without even going
looking at the specifics so this is
because some of you might have guessed
it already you have 21 places or 21 bits
for the exponent so one one of those
gets hit you're going to cause a large
deviation and you go to result in
complete miss classification you can't
tell from this graph and I'll show you
in the next graph that the that the
actual data type even we need float and
float 16 etc actually makes quite a lot
of difference in terms of the
sensitivity as does the kind of neural
network layer but to take away here at
least from a high level is that you know
the you see that there can be actually
be significant amount of state exposed
when you're using these wide data types
and that can cause is DC another thing
also you might notice is that they're
actually not that much difference
between the difference there's DC types
despite what I said in the previous
slide we looked at all these different
kinds of as DC's but you know we found
that actually they don't matter much in
practice but the difference so from now
on we said okay we just go with SDC one
because it seems like the results are
similar and intuitively why this is the
case is you have thousand possible
entries let's say you have a random
fault okay
something just randomly misclassifies it
the chance of that random is
classification being in the top fire of
thousand is actually very small so
whether it's the top one of the top fire
or the top the confidence being less
than 10% that's not such an important
metric yes why would you design a thing
that had 24 bits of extra that's a giant
range that your Express
relative to the number of bits in the
answer that's an excellent question so
one thing is many of these DNA
accelerators they they design to be
general as general as possible right so
you don't want to be so if you if you
didn't accommodate that you don't want
to be stuck with the choices you made so
one of the takeaways we're going to get
to is that it's better to you strain it
into type as much as possible for the
specific being and you're trying to run
rather than make one accelerator to rule
them all that very general because this
gives you this large amount of of bit
space that could go wrong right so in
fact that was the second question right
so we looked at how sensitive are the
different bits and on the top you see
for the exponent bits and for the
floating-point data types and so the
fixed point data types again for the for
the bits that encode the exponent to the
other side of the binary point and no
and at a very high level the exponent
bits are the ones that are very
sensitive to errors as you would expect
because another the mantissa
no problem the neural network is
resilient it'll converge but you have an
error in the exponent and we look at
exactly what kinds of errors those are
in a second but that can lead to large
probability of silent interconnection so
again this reinforces the the result
that you're better off designing your
data types to be exact or as close as
possible to the dynamic ranges of values
yeah and no easier
your data space should really be small
in the sense of not spending a lot of
orders of magnitude
that's kind that easy to do for neural
networks tend to have that property are
their values okay that's actually an
excellent question because that's the
next question not always
okay but it turns out in most of these
cases the values clustered around zero
so there have been other studies of
theoretical analysis in the network
where they show that the values
eventually converge around zero and the
further he deviates from zero the higher
the probability that you're going to get
a wrong answer and that's exactly the
intuition here so this shows so these
graphs show the neuron values and
probability of a silent data corruption
the the Reds are the faulty ones the
greens are the correct values so this
would float 16 and these are for silent
data corruption these are the ones that
result in benign so off right away even
without perhaps squinting to a heart of
the graph you can see that for the
sudden data corruption once the values
are actually go all over the place from
the correct value right the correct
value is near zero
so the further you cause deviation from
zero the harder it is for the doodlenet
work to converge and as a result you
might end up with a sullen data
corruption but as the distribution is
more even in case of benign right so it
doesn't you don't get this runaway
effects become just the neural network
for its correct functioning required it
so you're saying it convergence they get
right right yeah beginning do you need
these values or so many orders of
magnitude different zero I see I see
I'm not gonna have any right specific so
that's been worked for example in the
community that looks at the power
consumption for different dynamic ranges
of these values and one of their
conclusions will also keep the power
consumption low you've got to learn the
characteristics of a visual Network and
design data types exactly to fit that so
there is some so so so what does argues
for is more specialization rather than
make it a general actually in a platform
so if I know you're going to run neural
networks which have small dynamic ranges
then I
try to pick my data data types to fit
those dynamic ranges yes that's also as
a designer you have the choice to use
those networks of course they may take
longer to convert or they may be slower
but that's good for both energy as well
as resilience so that's the message that
but thank you but for this glass here is
only the 40 distribution we store the
current value distribution so I'll
actually use this result later also to
design what we call software you know
the symptom based detectors which are in
software where you can dynamically bound
the range of these neuronal values so if
it's outside that range chances are is
going to be a silent data corruption so
you you you stop data from propagating
so we look at that in a few slides now
looking at the distribution by layer I
apologize for the quality of the graph
there but it's in a paper as well so
what we do is we have these three noodle
networks alex net cafe net and i and
those are more or less in a similar
range and coordinate one thing I should
have mentioned earlier z-- coordinate
doesn't have what's called the
renormalization so you know it these
three these networks do and there you
will actually see the effect of that so
you see at least alex net and cafe net
do so you see when when you have the the
fault in the first two layers which are
doing the normalization actually the
probability of it being a cylindrical
corruption is very low because it's
bringing the value back to the to the
acceptable bound and after that you have
a fault it keeps going up and the reason
it it spikes to as endless the last two
layers are fully connected in this
network so you have one fault it's going
to get spread everywhere all over the
place that maybe that's where you know
that particular example is coming from
where you have a fault in the last layer
later layer is going to get spread and
there's no renormalization to bring it
back whereas in the anion case actually
there is a normalization layer towards
end as well so that's another lesson you
can learn from from this right so you
might help to actually put normalization
layers towards end so you bring the
value back to an acceptable range rather
than spread it all over the place now
what
one other thing also is you probably
asked you keep increasing the layers
your probability of a silent era
corruption increases so a fault early on
may not matter as much a fault later the
execution may be much more consequential
the same graph you can see with the
Euclidean distance of the values so we
measure the distance within the value
correct value and the faulty value for
the different networks and again you
seen an extent and cafe net the the
Euclidean distance actually can drops
quite sharply or on layer two and then
stays there as these other two guys know
the value can be quite significantly
different so the idea in again there's
one thing to cover here but the further
you go from the correct convergent value
of zero the higher the chance of SDC and
you want to put layers that actually
bring that value closer to that so the
the local response normalization or lrn
layer and they wanted to renormalize as
the value back towards the normal range
and then you know you so you want to put
such layers in your networks if at all
possible to keep the value bounded so
now you might say okay what is the use
of all this what if I don't really have
ability to choose the neural networks I
wanted on is there anything as I you
know as a chip design I can do to
mitigate these faults so one thing
that's that that you can do is you can
choose narrow data data types so for
example you can choose 32 BRB 26 which
is you have 26 bits for your exponent
for your for your you know the mantissa
and just five bits for the exponent
rather than this other one where you're
up to 21 with full exponent because that
can vary widely but then you can say how
much difference does it actually make in
practice so here we have to use some
some projections because the the IDIS
architecture i talked about is formal it
was fabricated at 128 nanometer so we
want to look at the effect on funny
eight nanometer which is the current
technology or even lower so we use some
results from a paper and nuclear
engineering where they did these Neutron
flux measurements and scaled it down so
had collaborators wouldn't you this not
be personally but what we ended up doing
was to project the actual cell the the
fit rate or for
these different architectures and as it
turns out if you use the the wider data
type your fit trade can be about 16 just
for the DLN accelerator and this is a
problem because remember I told you the
fit rate has to be less than 10 right
and that includes whole ship not just
accelerator whereas if you're judicious
about your choice of data drive you can
actually bring it down quite a bit so
here's an easy fix right so you can
choose the data type that actually fits
the neural network you wanna implement
and bring down the fit rate by almost an
order of magnitude right from fifty
eight point two to five point something
so this is one easy thing you could know
to keep the values restrained but what
if this wasn't enough what if you had
other parts of the what if you wanted to
bring the filtrate even lower so here we
are proposing symptom is error detectors
that can be done in software so the end
of each layer you you you can check
whether the value deviates from zero by
a significant amount and detected or you
can learn the correct ranges over a
period of time and then you can run the
rain check so that if the value deviates
too much from the correct one then
you're going to stop the network from
computing and we find that if you did
this you can actually it's a fairly
simple rain check at a very simple level
and the recall of this can be about 93%
with ninety percent precision so you can
actually abound the ranges fairly
tightly and a fairly predictable for the
class of neural networks a study so this
is something you do in software if you
want to be even more sort of you want to
guarantee your fit rates are bounded you
can also do things like selectively
protect certain latches in hardware of
course this assumes that you are the
designer of the accelerator platform so
you you can decide which latches to
duplicate so the the the sort of the
baseline would be duplicate everything
but that leads to huge overheads so the
so here we say for a given flip-flop
target rate reduction what is overhead
and TMR is triple modular redundancy
duplicate everything three times and
there are a bunch of other strategies
here and and the important thing is the
curve has this reverse exponential kind
of distribution here if you look at this
action of vertical notches so with by
predicting about 20% of the laches you
can rig no infiltrate by 80% right and
of course you get to the last any person
you've got to pay the rest of the cost
so this is an important result because
it means that you can go after the
low-hanging fruit and get pretty big
wins yes you don't get hundred-percent
connection but you get 80% of the
filtrate reduction just by predicting
about 20% lattice so you you don't have
to duplicate everything for example
because that has its own attendant cost
so this is based on a theoretical model
that one of my quarters derived so so
we've tested this on regular CPUs but
this is still something you're testing
along the DN and actually in a platform
because we have to go and refabricate
the whole chip to to incorporate this so
but the takeaway here is with 20%
overhead you can get almost hundred x
reduction in the effect rate so what we
did in this product was a characterized
at a propagation in DNA and accelerators
we looked at different different
parameters data type layers value types
and different topologies and presented
three mitigation methods I'm not saying
these are the these are panacea but
these do restrict these do bring down
the fit rate considerably so things like
restraining the value range of the data
type if you can do that depending on
your neural network design adding adding
a value range checker and and you know
we show that you can do this is pretty
low overhead in software and selective
latch hardening if you actually are able
to modify the hardware so they take away
here is if you're if you can adapt your
fault tolerance technique to the
characteristics of the application or
the neural network you can get much
better protection than the generic one
size fits all approaches so is your
possibility is it dynamically
determining what the range is that's not
exactly it's done in software because at
the end of each layer you can look at
the output values so you're reusing the
same hardware for each layer right so
yeah
feedback the values on software and then
you can we are on the checksum software
and in fact you can use the CTO to roll
the check because the CPU sitting idle
while the diem
oh if we say you your own values you
mean those values after each layer but
not the temporary variables the output
of each layer what well I don't know if
you wanna they are temporary if I look
at it if I look at the noodle network as
a black box right but they are the
values that are produced under feature
they are variables right so those are
the one who is the output of each layer
do you want to put a range for this well
that's what we do actually learn the
ranges of the outputs of each layer but
in between the outputs there are the
country variables what you don't care
about okay so for us what output of each
layer I mean the actual values
communicated between the layers not not
just the ones that end up in thanks any
other questions it's fine okay so now
I'm going to tell tell you about
something that is quite different but
has the same theme which is that we want
to build intrusion detection systems for
these cyber-physical systems and we're
going to use dynamic invariance here so
the motivation here is we want to
provide low low cost security for
cyber-physical systems so we want to
satisfy resource as well as real time
constraints no human intervention needed
and we wanted to be able to detect
zero-day attacks as far as possible so
we we don't want to be having to upgrade
our signatures in the field for these
devices and so on so so we want to as
much as possible make these systems the
autonomous and capable of running
intuition detection software on their
own on the on the on the host without
relying on a network connection for
example so here we go to leverage the
properties of this type of physical
system so we're going to look at so most
of the cyber physical system we consider
have timing predictability what does
this mean they have to send a message
every X second they have to send a pulse
they have to do this loop within a
minute for example so there are timing
constraints that are part of the
specification and we're going to exploit
this and use time as a first-class
constraint to detect intrusions and so
then the idea is actually
in forward we learn the invariance based
on the dynamic execution and we monitor
these invariants at runtime to see if
they're violet so so let me sort of a
little bit about the threat model we
consider so this is the model of the
cyber-physical system there's a
communication network the physical
process and your cyber process it should
be a control algorithm and physical
process is sending in measurements to
the cyber process and it's sending
actuation the mods so we are we are
looking at attacks attacks can occur in
any part here it can occur in the cyber
process in the physical process or in
the command send so we are not looking
at attacks in the physical process so if
you attack the physical process we learn
the wrong values but what we are doing
is we are trying to learn the invariance
from the cyber process and use these for
intrusion detection so very simple
example would be lets say this was a
smart meter let's say let's say it's a
card and you know that your current
value of speed can't be greater than the
previous speed value by more than a
certain pressure so this has been very
into you could learn so that if there is
a attack that tries to compromise this
you would be able to tell you detected
so of course we are not the first to
come up with intrusion detection systems
there's been a ton of work here so the
classical ones are signature based IDS's
where you have to give it a bunch of
attack signatures these don't quite a
work for the system because you need to
update the signatures on the fly and you
want to want the ability to provide
zero-day attack detection and then
there's also work on are normally based
ideas where you learn some statistical
models of the behavior but those are
false positives and there's other work
that's shown that these are less than
suitable for these systems because you
don't have a human on the loops that you
can alert when there's a false possible
having said that what I'm going to talk
about is also related to that so we come
back to that kill
then there are specification based ideas
where you learn a specification of what
the software is doing and then you try
to detect attacks so you can do that
through static analysis but
unfortunately in these cyber-physical
systems there's a lot of interaction
with the environment at typical static
analysis doesn't capture this and as you
go out of your way to model the
environment right so what we are doing
is we are going to use dynamic analysis
so we're going to learn the invariance
by monitoring the system
over a period of time and then use the
invariance to go and detect attacks so
this is this is the sort of smaller
sample on day so what's an invariant
many of you have probably familiar but
just to give example so it's a energy
use it should be greater than or equal
to zero or the current minus the past
value should be less than or equal to
threshold or or some other sequence of
values should you know some other value
should fall into a certain sequence and
so on so there's been a lot of work on
dynamic invariant detection in the
software engineering space so starting
from daikon from u-dub and you know
there's been work on tech sada for
distributed system perfume for mining
properties of the active systems and so
on and the common thing but all of these
systems is they look at only one of two
dimensions of data time or even so if
you look at events cyber physical
systems are going to send receive
messages and those are events for
example time of course know what is in
data as is the data values are changing
right so if you look at daikon for
example which is one of the classic
dynamic invariant detection systems they
only looked at the data how the data
actually changes right there's other
work that's looked at this they even
patterns or looks at events and time and
our insight here is that you actually
need to look at data time as well as
even the interplay between all these
three because that's really where some
of the interesting attacks are going to
try to break your invariance and I'll
give you an example later but you know
in a nutshell what happens is in this
type of physical systems they have to be
predictable data value change changes at
certain times and we want to be able to
learn those invariants and if you try to
change the value prematurely or you
don't let the value chain or you
suppress an event that suppose I can at
a certain time then we will detect that
now this will not work for a regular
general desktop computer because you
don't have that level of timing
predictability in a typical application
but the applications that run on these
devices are simple and they follow this
kind of repeated patterns so that's the
secret sauce if you will that lets us
actually go and detect these invariants
so so if I plot if you look at data
event and time so I won one up one way
to learn these invariants would be to
simply look at all these free variables
and navigate that space the problem is
however this leads to state space blow
up because this you know almost every
pattern you can think of you can learn
between these three dimensions so the
the insight we are going to leverage
here is I can actually look at data
event and time conditioned upon the
event space so cyber-physical systems
are very even driven so there's usually
a explicit command so if we look we go
back to the sliders already where we're
sending a command to a physical process
getting measurements each of these is a
diamond so you're reacting to some
external events and the idea is I can
break up the space by events and learn
the data values that has to change as
well as the time properties of the event
so I can use this to come up with
invariants so the system we build is
karate nollie so it's going to condition
data changes on events as time events
there's a we show on the paper this is
equivalent to learning data even in time
it's just based probability and what we
end up doing is we end up deriving data
per event invariance time for even
invariance and data per time invariance
so all these three together we can leave
an edge and say okay this data has to
change in response to this event at a
certain time so that's the idea so we
built this system or RT nolle where you
give it the program under test so you
you still have to log the events
yourself this is common to many of these
other event logging systems as well so
when I'm theory you could have you could
have built a front-end to do that
automatically but once you do the log
everything else is automatic so we will
derive the data per event the event per
time and then derive the data of a time
and then feed this directly to the
intrusion detection system so it will
use these invariants and look for
violations of them to detect an attack
so we evaluated this on two platforms so
one thing I should mention here is you
know there aren't that many open source
also we try to pick open so system so
that we can
define security loopholes and evaluated
on our system this is not a requirement
but it just makes our life easier in
terms of evaluation so there aren't that
many open-source cyber-physical systems
we could use so we found two one was an
advanced metering infrastructure called
seg meter so this is a real smart meter
and we can actually look at a code it's
running a Linux place variant and we can
know look at--look run our system on it
and then there's also a smart an
artificial pancreas it's an open-source
project for people with type 1 diabetes
when they have to have a control loop to
monitor insulin levels and so on so
these were two systems that we used to
test our evaluation and what we did is
so we took this cyber-physical system
generated a whole bunch of traces just
normal operation of the system with
different events and so on and then we
we had a learning phase where we took
some places learn the invariants and
then we come back then we also had from
the intrusion detection phase where as
the traces were being generated they
were fed to our intrusion detector and
what violated the invariant we would
we'll replace an attack flag to keep the
comparison fair we compared with or
rather we compared with with three other
systems died context around perfume so
these systems do not sorry do not have
the data that the time constraint so
they look at data over event event over
time and so on they do look at data
event at time the Tatiana leaders so and
then we see that the invariance from
each of these systems in turn and then
checked how good they were at detecting
intrusions
so we wanted to make it an
apples-to-apples comparison so any trace
that we got we to run it against all the
invariants and check which of them will
actually detect the security attack I
mean what what did we actually do also
for the sec meter we just let the meter
run for a day every and it was
generating these traces I mean even with
randomly sample at different points of
the day
this hooked up L'Oreal Paris yeah so
spending communicating with the server
with the open apps we didn't have a real
insulin pump or a question so we use
some data that was released by the
National Diet Association to assimilate
different conditions of typical patient
even and then ran into that so this is
what they recommend that you use to to
test the system and operation yeah I
guess it's a challenge if you're gonna
do intrusion detection to have a sense
of the variety of the in the wild what
they kind of behavior behaviors these
things are gonna say right right so one
thing we don't need those are set of
attacks right because they're
characterizing the good behavior of the
system
yeah but you're right that is going to
be your challenge yes so you must have
some time lag you must need to see some
amount of the trace before you start
yeah cuz I mean the very first yeah
you've got detected by even you say oh
my invariance three yep next one's five
I quote that's an intrusion yeah yeah so
so okay Poppa's an experiment so we
haven't actually gone and measured what
that time needs to be to get a
theoretical bound for the purpose of
experiment I believe we ran it with like
50 traces so however long in the in the
case of the smart meter that took about
an hour to generate in the case of the
insulin power traces in the next race
and the next race also be partitioned
that's I'll show you how we stopped but
but you bring up a good point right so
you can make this intrusion detection
systems being very whole open it like
very highly called by just curing the
parameters appropriately and we try to
be balanced I'll show you how we did
that here to come up with the universal
kind of intrusion detection or no
parameter system for system introduced I
mean a pro-family you you have you have
an intrusion detection system which is
trained using so for particular meter
let's say right you you run the
intrusion detection you run the
invariant generator and then feed it to
the idea so for that meter it will go on
monitor and stuff because there are
thousands of
Emily and then if Mike's family he has
to run the the training yeah I think
that's the model we're using now having
said that you know for a particular
class of devices we don't believe that
we different variation but we haven't
explored that so that's a that's an
interesting question right how much how
much cross learning can i benefit from
it and here we are learning it for our
particular system and trying to detect
intrusions on that system in terms of
this training phase coverage so
oh you mean coverage of the inputs yeah
so we don't but we do measure false
positives and false negatives right and
we can look at how to balance those two
so so yeah but the assumption is that
you you be able to see all the behaviors
in the first few minutes of training
which is which will impact a false
positive rate so I'm gonna show you so
the first thing I want to say is you
know when we built a system like this
one question is how do you evaluate it
so we tried to come up with attacks
ourselves on these middle and entry and
smart APs
so this is a by its definition it is a
it is a doctoral in the sense we try to
take attacks that other papers have
discovered on these class of systems and
try to replicate it in a lab and we were
able to do it and in this case we were
able to actually detect all the tax that
we targeted but this by itself is not
sufficient right because one of our
goals was to detect zero-day attacks so
yes this is a low bar to meet we took a
bunch of attacks we motored them we
detected them but it's by no means
enough because I don't mean an attacker
can do arbitrary things right so how do
I emulate that so so one thing we try to
do is we try to emulate what an
arbitrary attacker would do for using
fault injection or mutation testing so
this is where you know in the absence of
data about exactly what an attacker
would do we have to be here to make
worst-case assumptions and say alright
if an attacker somehow manages to flip a
branch or somehow manage to mutate the
value am I able to detect that with my
with my assertions so so for example
here we did data mutation for a
different kinds of
winters for example at integer values to
immolate integer overflows and so on we
did branch flipping so he said in so
going down the if part the then power to
go down the else part or we tried to
introduce delays at random places so in
when I was here last year I spoke about
this project that he had a model shaker
to godiscover attacks against smart
meter so one of the things we found that
from the model checker found was even by
delaying synchronization putting the
server and the meter you could actually
introduce attack so we we tried to use
that knowledge of of the kinds of
attacks that could occur here but we had
to do this you know in a sort of blind
way to be unbiased so we we did a bunch
of these mutations I forget the exact
number that's in a paper and try to get
statistical estimates of how many were
detected and so on so now we come to the
important question of false negative
versus false positive right so depending
on how you tune the ideas you can have
more false negatives of false positives
so I will try with the definitions of
these but what we tried to do was we
measured what's one of the F score so it
tries to balance some false positive
false negative it's a standard determine
information retrieval so so there's this
parameter called beta which lets you
choose which one to prioritize more so
if you have beta greater than 1 you'll
prioritize false negative higher so you
want fewer false negatives beta equal to
1 equal and beta less than 1 the other
way now so for the smart meter we said
you know the worst case that happens if
you have a false negative is you know
some money somebody steals your power so
it's probably not as bad but you don't
want false positives because if your
utility provider you don't want to come
look at a false alarm every few minutes
right that's a cost
so there we prioritize false so we said
we we let a few false negatives slide
but heat spread has false positives for
the medical device which is you the
other way don't know that's an argue you
could argue both ways but our rationale
was you don't want an attack to slip
through even if it means a logically
human every now and then it's probably
fine because you're marrying the device
so here's one example of what we of the
kind of tuning we did so the x-axis is
the number of training places the y-axis
is the percentage for different false
positives false negatives an F score
balance okay so here you'll see oh and
and therefore actually for the different
F scores so this is what open apps so
you'll see that the false positive rate
keeps decreasing as you increase number
of training phases but your false
negative rate might increase but it also
stabilizes at some point right because
you're going to get going to reach
saturation now we could so this is for
one particular IDs that one we generator
the artena Ling variance for a platform
so we can for this we can find the
optimal number of training traces that
maximize F score which happens to be
around 15 or you could you know you
could go higher as well if you chose to
but the important thing is this kind of
training is very platform specific very
idea specific so we have to do this for
all the ideas for all the platforms and
what we are going to do is so for every
system be it texana or daikon or perfume
we try to find the point at which that
particular value of F score is maximized
so that's the best Ferrum configuration
for that system and then we compare it
to the best qualification for our system
so in a sense we're looking at the best
case for each of these systems we could
have done it for average case and worst
case as well but it's important to make
sure that all of the same even key so
first let's look at the false negative
rate here we looking at the two values
so this is 95% confidence interval so we
looked at different kinds of attacks or
arbitrary like data a mutation branch
flipping artificial delays and so on and
one thing you see is with these other
three systems the false negative rate
for I mean first of all it varied
depending on the kind of attacks you
were generating so an example would be
daikon is very good at detecting data
mutation attacks because it was doing
data invariance right let us perfume for
example we're just looking more to the
timing of events was very good at
detecting artificial delays but our teen
Ally was good at detecting all the three
because it was it was looking at the the
intersection so it was looking at data
event and time
so overall the false negative rate
without in earlier system was much lower
than the false negative rate with each
of these system the white bars are the
aggregate and for negative rates so in
fact it's about two to two percent so
that means only two percent of the time
we miss the attack whereas with some of
these systems it could be as high as 90%
or 50% on average so so again this is
just because we are able to say
specifically at this time at this event
this years of the data value should
change so an attacker has very little
freedom to change things and get away
with it the story is not however as
sanguine for the false-positive case
though we end up doing better than the
other system so here if you look at dye
context our perfume the false positive
rate is pretty high in the defense of
those system I'll say they were not
meant for security your intrusion
detection there were for software
engineering so they had a programmer
look at the invariants so they for them
a false positive was fine as long as a
programmer could be validated quickly
for us we don't have that but even so
you know a false positive rate was about
12% so we were still improving on the
other system but there's still we still
think this is pretty high so you know we
do need to bring the false positive rate
down but I'll tell you this one of the
things that brings a false positive rate
dominance the the chance of a
coincidental path where the data event
and time exactly matched the correct one
is actually lower because you look here
three things as opposed to any two or
just one so we could do better if you
actually started sub classifying the
kinds of paths the software was taking
for example which we don't do we just
learn it as one aggregate thing for
example if I say when was the spot
communicated to the server and
I'm going to learn one kind of invariant
and when it's a start sensing the power
values I'm gonna know what kind of it
married so this will require us to
customize the invariant generation
system we try not to do that but that's
one way we can bring down the false
positive rate but even without doing all
that we're still doing better than this
other system but there is room for
improvement and of course the big thing
is performance because performance and
memory because these systems are very
resource constrained so the results was
a smart meter platform we have over four
megabytes of memory to use because the
Linux it's 16 mb ram and then the linux
image and other things take 2 l mb so
that's that's the limit we are operating
under so one thing is all the system's
end up being about similar so you know
the the invariance being stored about
three megabytes which is still less than
that but even in the worst case perfume
still is less than 4 MB so it's fine the
more important thing is the detection
time so there's performance over it so
we impose
33% overhead which is also comparable to
other systems but what does this mean
with reality so in the case of spot
beat-up it's sensing the power values
taking some action sensing the power
values and so on this loop happens every
one second so you have to finish
whatever your ideas does in that one it
sorry it happens every one minute so you
have to finish whatever your idea is
that's in that minute otherwise you're
going to you won't be able to keep up
right and we find that we can finish
within the first ten or fifteen seconds
so that's also the detection latency so
we can so as long as we are within that
minute you can you have more room for
example yeah so you're running whatever
load the manufacturer so that's already
that in the worst case but but you know
our overheads are still we have rhythm
like twenty five percent twenty five to
thirty percent of the of the time so
there is room to actually have even this
certain workload for whatever the
process of running it should still be
okay but having said these are not data
centers or clouds I have it probably not
running very compute heavy stuff on it
so that's the other side of it but we
are able to make sure that whatever load
we impose it doesn't affect the
real-time performance of the system so
for these two systems
so to summarize Artie nollie is a
multi-dimensional model for
cyber-physical systems we capture the
data event time into play and we have
real-time data invariance here I mean I
say coverage I don't mean coverage in
this form of test coverage I mean
coverage to undeveloped not actively
introduced so that increased and it
decreases the rate of false positives
but there's still room to improve that
and the overheads are comparable to
other invariant detection systems but
the goal I want to emphasize is you know
not naught that Artie nollie by itself
is a panacea it does still room to make
improve it but the idea of applying
dynamic invariant detection is important
with these domains because you can't
have programmers go or write
specifications for you so and these
embedded systems do very specific tasks
so I think there is a lot of opportunity
here in terms of coming up with generic
variant detection systems that can learn
automatically without the programmer
having to describe write specifications
and then to feed these back for both
security as well as reliability and
right now we are actually trying to run
this on a UAV so we have a drone that we
are trying to attack and you know proven
the drone for crashing just in time by
running RT gnarly but that still work in
progress so yes so so you're saying so
it was 90 seconds for all the processing
and then the processor just so sorry
that is a workload that's already
running right that the UN loop and
things happen in that one minute okay so
it reads the values into some
calculations
sometimes it just sits idle and so on
our idea is running in a parallel
process so it's running in a separate
process separate process which uses a
pipe processor we need another processor
the running standard Linux you know
scheduling it's one processor okay but
running two processes so - so we are so
so we didn't observe that so we in our
test we never missed the deadline so
that's the so you're right I don't have
a proof here that we will never ever
miss a deadline but empirically and the
now we finished our IDs process in the
first 20 seconds of the minute we have
so that leads me to believe you're not
you know let's say I agree with you I
mean one thing would be nice to do is to
say I can bound the amount of overhead I
introduced with this but but but I will
say this however we can prioritize which
parts of the code to monitor so we can
if we find that we are close to the brim
go to overflow our time we could say I'm
going to monitor fewer invariance
so of course you trade off coverage so
we had another server crabby of trying
to model this is like a set cover
problem I have a property I want to
establish what is the minimum mode of
invariance I have to I have to monitor
to establish the property and you can
treat it like a no integer linear
programming problem right so but but I
agree with you I mean what we have is a
moronic total demonstration that it
doesn't affect the real-time operation
but it'd be nice to have a proof so I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
some of the ongoing work in my group and
then conclude so so so I spoke about
some of the work we did on formal
methods to use model checking to find
attacks again the spot Peter so we had
this high level model of the smart Peter
in Maude or rewriting logic then we ran
the model checker and it found lot of
regular attacks so I spoke about this
last time I was here where we had things
like you could tamper with say the the
communication between the two booths so
this is a commodity smart meter we
bought of eBay so it doesn't catch some
protection but nothing major so you can
easily open it up and you know we could
do things like we connected a timer
which would send a pulse to the meter
exactly at a certain time and reboot it
and nine times out of ten we've worked
out all the data that was stored on it
at that time and you know be so Monica
found many of these attacks but what it
required was this high-level model of
this so we're now trying to see if we
can do this without having the
programmer write that high-level model
so we're trying to model these attacks
directly in the code a symbolic
execution through symbolic infusion and
then we're going to try and use these
invariants with the model check on to
show that the invariants are sufficient
for establishing a certain property so
this is still work in progress but
that's the goal right so ultimately we
want to have a system that comes up with
these specific these invariants and then
automatically the model checker goes and
tries to find attacks and then it's it
finds an attack let's chain and the we
come up with new invariants to to detect
the attack and so on so to have the
self-improving capability in ideas but
we are not there yet
another reason project we started my
group is trying to build smart
middleware for IOT devices so while you
know you've done a bunch of work on
JavaScript for the web there is a lot of
effort to run JavaScript on IOT devices
so Samsung Intel have VMs that actually
run JavaScript JavaScript VMs or have
tiny embedded devices but today to
program these you still have to program
them on a device specific basis so our
goal is to try to make to come up with a
framework for programming IOT devices so
that you write JavaScript code in one
place and the framework takes care of
distributing the computation sending the
chunks of code by grading them
scheduling them and so on so we call the
smart J's but the name may change so we
have some examples of code that we can
you know migrate on the fly without
requiring the programmer to do anything
so one of the challenges here is keeping
track of closure state without modifying
the VM I'm happy to talk about this
offline if anyone is interested but this
is a reason project we started and more
broadly going back to the DNN case I
think what this calls for is we need to
think about resilience of machine
learning applications so today the
problem is I mean there's a lot of work
on adversarial machine learning when you
change inputs and so on but what if you
are able to change the actual parameters
of the ML algorithm or change the
implementation or the hardware that runs
it so what we want is to build
algorithms that are resilient to
perturbations even of the parameter so
for example if you have say an algorithm
it goes off on a different path for a
small change in parameter that's not a
very resilient one so can I build
machine learning algorithms or free
learning systems where a small chain
doesn't introduce large changes in
output so this is something looking at a
bunch of the theoretical machine
learning folks trying to see if we can
bound the algorithmic resilience of
these of these systems so to conclude I
hope I've convinced you that cyber
physical systems resilience and security
a important challenges so we look at two
systems in this context deep neural
network accelerators for self-driving
cars and invariant monitoring for
embedded system security in this future
work we want to do formal analysis to
actually prove properties about
these systems will the presence of our
mitigation mechanisms as well as build
smart runtimes
for these to help programmers write
resilient code and finally interested in
looking at resilient machine learning
algorithms as well as systems in the
broad sense so with that I'm happy to
take given more questions and that's my
email address there in case you have
more questions okay thank you very much
well you use formal analysis to the the
adversary model is different right now
it flips its orbit so thank you for that
question so here we are assuming
diversity that can tamper with the
physical interfaces of the system so
I'll give you an example so so you can
reboot the system at any point in time
let's say right which is straightforward
you just plug in clock out you could
read see you so these meters have a
serial port okay you can plug a serial
port cable and read the data so the
video is you've not even if it's
encrypted doesn't matter
the middle register then it has being
read and the third attack there is we
can drop certain messages sent to the
server so I can drop all the timing
synchronization messages it is not
something very well we assume that okay
so we assume that your tanker is not
like a nation-state or someone who has
deep pockets right to go and do the kind
of thing like when they can reverse and
you the whole chip and so on what they
can do is they can tamper with the
physical interfaces which is so all the
stuff at actually mounted we we bought
the equipment of eBay like for less than
$50 so a solid-state timer costs $10 for
example so you can actually hook it up
to your meter and send the reboot pulse
at the right time but the model chick
had said that your reboot when when you
come to this function in the core and
then look the beat loses data so that's
true but but from that to actually
translation to the physical attack most
rates although so I don't know if I
answered your question
so all the tax there are done on the
real meat of it
equipment bought of VB him for ready no
cost which is what we are the typical
anti-government you talk about the
modeling and your whether or not and not
expecting people to know these models of
[Applause]
yeah that's a great question we've
talked to some companies that do these
IOT device development and the the the
feedback we got was they started the
model but the more the Cody walls are
the models often updated so you're right
so many of these devices are well they
glorified state machines right so you do
have to have a model of the device but
by the time the code goes through
iterations and ready for shipping they
don't necessarily keep the model
up-to-date so in fact when we when we
were trying to pitch it to a company
that does IOT device development and the
back regards we can't rely on the model
so we initially started off by saying
give us your model we'll turn that it
invariance but then because the model
turned out to be not I couldn't we said
can we learn the invariance erect liriko
but but you're right if there is a use
the language like P absolutely so in
fact you know for the formal modeling
work we assume the the programmer
actually expense the the code in higher
level model rewriting logic and I don't
know the specifics of P but from what I
know I assume it is a high level logic
to express your program so yes certainly
we could do better in variance in that
case and you know we don't have false
positives I so this is just my personal
take right so many of the programmers we
spoke to at least who were on product
they were not necessarily serious majors
many of them had engineering backgrounds
but no few of the other formal methods
or were able to describe the program at
a high in a high level logic so they
were writing direct C code
stressing as a state machine on the
board yeah yeah on the whiteboard sorry
no not actually I say so they give us
some sheets of paper or human diagrams
and some yes but they are more but not
actually as not the way a serious person
would think of at the morning yeah but
maybe it was just this one or two
companies we spoke to maybe there are
elected to actually do a more division
job but I remember the beginning of P
was windows developers would join the
state machine on PowerPoint oh yeah it's
the same story I said except they have
it such a big thing it couldn't fit
another worker it's right I mean I don't
have been a lot of work on model-based
code generation in the software learning
community where people would say okay
you know let me express the state
machine has generate the code
automatically and so on I don't know
whether those tools are actually used to
measure it's a real thing okay I would
love to know
okay